[Musique]
oui
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
session intitulée affronter les
changements climatiques est très
heureuse de vous retrouver pour ce débat
d'actualité la pandémie de co vider le
confinement ont mis en lumière l'impact
de nos modes de vie sur la planète et
par ricochet l'urgence d'accélérer la
transition écologique
pourtant face à la crise économique qui
frappe durement les entreprises
certains secteurs sont ou ont été tentés
de demander des délais supplémentaires
pour suivre la trajectoire de
décarbonation d'économies qui étaient
fixés notamment au plan européen
en france l'état a conditionné certaines
aides à des engagements liés à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique c'est
le cas notamment pour l'aérien mais
l'ampleur de ses efforts et leur suivi
fait débat reste que globalement le
monde économique ne peut plus passer
sous silence cette problématique du
réchauffement climatique
place maintenant à l'action mais est-ce
si simple qui plus est dans ce contexte
de crise pour en parler
cinq personnes avec nous en studio
catherine guillouard bonjour bonjour à
tous vous êtes pdg du groupe ratp
entreprises publiques qui opère le
réseau de transport parisien et une
partie de celui de l'ile-de-france mais
et c'est peut être moins connus qui
exploite aussi des réseaux de transport
de voyageurs dans 12 pays sur quatre
continents avoue côté denis lucquin
managing partner de sofinnova partners
un fonds de capital risque qui investit
dans les sciences de la vie bonjour vous
êtes récemment engagé dans la transition
écologique également avec nous sylvie
jehanno pdg de dalkia filiale d'edf
spécialisée dans les services
énergétiques et notamment les énergies
renouvelables bonjour bonjour à tous et
merci d'être avec nous et merci
également à bertrand camus d'être avec
nous pour cette table ronde directeur
général de suez numéro deux mondial des
services à l'environnement dont les
métiers de l'eau l'assainissement la
collecte et la valorisation des déchets
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous et à
vos côtés jean marc jancovici et
président du groupe de réflexion the
shift project bonjour monsieur bonjour
mais avant de vous entendre les uns et
les autres bertrand badré qui nous vient
d'ailleurs spécialement des états unis
modérateur de cette session pour le
cercle des économistes va nous dire
quelques mots d'introduction pour poser
aux plus précisément le cadre de notre
réflexion
bertrand badré vous êtes aussi fondateur
du fonds d'investissement dans le
développement durable blu line can
orange et ancien directeur de la banque
mondiale c'est à vous merci alors
bonjour bonjour à tous et à tout âge et
peut-être commencer par deux évidences
la première je suis parce que tous ceux
qui sont autour de la table sont aussi
extrêmement heureux que la question
climatique reste central au mieux la
période exceptionnelle que nous vivons
ce n'est pas garanti ya encore quelques
semaines ou quelques mois donc il faut
se réjouir de ce point la deuxième
évidence il a aussi ses il faut pas
contribuer à la confusion des esprits la
crise annie t elle en a eu avant il y en
aura après elle n'est pas au sens strict
10 une crise de l'environnement d'une
crise du capitalisme une crise d'autres
choses mais elles révèlent elles
exacerbent elle accentue des traits de
celle ci donc là aussi il faut faire la
part des choses et ne pas rendre tout
confus je pense qu'on va on va envoyer
travailler aujourd'hui
mais cette crise comme toutes les crises
elle nous oblige à nous poser un certain
nombre de questions et notamment parce
que après une crise et une sortie de
crise et donc comment on négocie la
sortie de crise alors moi j'ai beaucoup
passer de temps sur la crise précédente
était une crise financière
ce que nous avons fait à l'époque c'est
peut-être injuste mais c'est comme ça
que j'ai perçu on a rafistolé les
systèmes à coups de ratio de normes etc
bonne nouvelle on n'est pas mort
mauvaise nouvelle on n'a pas repenser
notre système on ne l'a pas en
particulier alignés sur les objectifs
décidés en 2015 sur le développement
durable et sur les accords de paris on
n'a pas repenser un système qui soit
cohérent avec la feuille de route que
techniquement l'humanité ces données ya
cinq ans donc nous avons de nouveau
cette question devant nous on va pouvoir
se reposer ces questions les entreprises
vont être amenés à se restructurer à se
réorganiser le font déjà aujourd'hui
l'état va mobiliser des ressources tout
le monde va se poser des questions sur
la suite et donc je pense que c'est
l'occasion de d'éviter de gâcher cette
thèse ce moment où on peut penser et
peut-être aller plus au fond que qu'au
moment de la crise précédente mais en
même temps il faut rester lucide il ya
un risque qui est permanent en plus des
contraintes notamment économiques et
financières de ce que les anglo saxons
appellerait le cri comme dirty levitt et
salle où le high carbonneau sociability
donc riche en carbone et pas très
durable pour des questions de vitesse
d'efficacité et c'est malgré tout et
toutes les pétitions qui ont été signés
partout sur la planète tous les appels
suis sûr que tous autour de la table on
a dû enseigner deux ou trois pour dire
moment il faut être vu
et c'est ça suffit pas et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça que je voudrais
attention sur laquelle je voudrais vous
attirer il faut être conscient que les
efforts individuels la bonne volonté en
partie des gens ici sont importantes
mais ne suffisent pas et donc il faut
être conscient qu'il va falloir par les
règles normes prix du carbone toute
chose qu'on n'aime pas tellement en
réalité est prise en compte des
externalités puisqu'on les économies
sont plus employés des gros mots comme
externalités et ça veut dire
concrètement qu'il va falloir ouvrir le
capot prendre ces outils et regardez le
moteur au sens propre du terme que c'est
difficile d'ouvrir le capot dans un
monde qui est divisée dans un monde n'y
a pas de maître du monde pour dire voilà
que les outils on va utiliser que c'est
encore un peu plus urgent aujourd'hui
que c'est l'été hier et que par ailleurs
comme je disais au début même s'il faut
pas être confus que ça n'est pas
indépendant les autres des dimensions de
cette crise dimension sanitaire
notamment dimension sociale je pense
qu'une dimension justice sociale qui ne
faudra pas oublier et donc il faut qu'on
ait une approche ici je crois qu'il ya
pas de meilleur panel pour ouvrir la
voie que celui qui a été réuni par le
cercle aujourd'hui à titre personnel
vous l'avez rappelé revenir des états
unis or pour le couler la crise
sanitaire n'est pas finie la crise
climatique est un vrai sujet politique à
la crise sociale est exacerbée c'est un
vrai bonheur va arriver à paris
aujourd'hui pour parler de manière
détendue et heureuse de tous ces sujets
merci à mort merci à vous on va
maintenant rentrer tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet si vous le voulez bien avec
un cadre concret je me tourne vers vous
catherine bidoire alors à la ratp vous
avez lancé un plan pour réduire de
moitié les émissions de dioxyde de
carbone entre 2015 et 2025 quels sont en
fait les solutions concrètes que vous
avez mis en place pour tenir cet
objectif bien écouter voilà alors
premièrement il faut savoir qu'en france
39% des gaz à effet de serre sont émis
par les transports
et si je suis très concrète à la ratp
70% de nos gaz à effet de serre son
ennemi par nos bus d'accord donc on a là
une des plus de large flotte de bus
d'europe
donc on est en train d'investir très
lourdement avec ile-de-france mobilité
note autorités régulatrices
on investit un milliard huit pour
changer tout simplement convertir
industriellement tous les dépôts de bus
au biogaz et à l'électrique et toute la
flotte de bus mais de façon plus
générale la ratp n'est pas qu'un
opérateur de mobilité
on est aussi un des plus vastes
gestionnaires d'infrastructures on a
toutes les infrastructures du métro
parisien
mais aussi du futur grand paris express
on est et c'est moins connu comme vous
le disiez aussi une grosse activité dans
l'immobilier et d'ailleurs on vient de
faire un partenariat des goûts des
hommes sur la construction bois qui va
s'occuper de saintes nos sites
industriels puisque on fait du mix
logement industriel sites industriels
comme par exemple des centres bull sur
lequel on construit des des écoles et
des logements sociaux
donc on fait des bouts de villes
intelligentes et durables et puis en
industriel on est aussi sur les sujets
de maintenance et les grands projets
d'extension de lignes donc en fait nous
on a trois axes baisser notre empreinte
carbone et par rapport au chiffre de 50
% à la fin 2019 on est déjà à -13%
on ad metrix qu'on suit de façon très
précise
deuxièmement plan de performance
énergétique donc on veut baisser notre
performance
on veut on veut arriver à baisser notre
consommation énergétique de 20% d'ici
2025 on est à -8% à la fin de l'année
2019 mais des chiffres et des résultats
en face nice va être précis et concret
le blabla c'est terminé actée et pour
faire ça on appris déjà les dires une
vision totalement matricielle dans
l'entreprise puisqu'on est la première
entreprise de transport au monde à avoir
obtenu une certification 50001 qui sont
le management de linguère de l'énergie
sur l'ensemble de nos activités c'est à
dire le bâtiment terre l'industriel les
solutions de mobilité
et puis en fait le dernier point mais
qu'est majeur pour nous c'est
l'adaptation au changement climatique
une petite anecdote 25 juillet l'année
dernière pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la ratp les rails tape 57°
première limitation de vitesse à 30 km
heure sur le réseau ferré parisien en
raison de ce changement climatique
donc ça veut dire que c'est devenu dans
notre management de risques l'adaptation
au changement climatique
un vrai sujet que nous suivons avec un
plan adapté qui qui regarde à la fois
l'impact sur les hommes puisque nos
personnels sont évidemment impacté il
faut le aussi penser à cela les
infrastructures et les matériels donc
voilà c'est c'est une activité si je
dire pour nous qui est au coeur de notre
stratégie et sur lesquels évidemment
sans cela il n'aurait pas de transport
public de demain il faut que ça soit la
décarbonation et je pense que évidemment
ça nécessite un fort niveau
d'investissement
un dernier chant bien 5 milliards 7
l'année dernière le chiffre d'affaires
du groupe 2 milliards sont investis dans
l'année 37 % du chiffre d'affaires
investis par le groupe ratp 1 milliards
750 g à dire avec au travers du contrat
l'ile-de-france mobilité 400 millions en
direct avec la société générale du grand
paris pour l'extension de lignes donc
c'est modernisation du réseau c'est
justement transition vers une flotte
verte
donc voilà c'est ces niveaux
d'investissement qu'il faut donc
effectivement la transition c'est aussi
de lourds investissements
mais ça passe par là alors les
investissements justement donné lui
qu'un savon comme tu connais puisque
avec sofinnova partners vous investissez
dans des start-up dans le domaine des
sciences de la vie et vous avez décidé
il ya peu près dix ans de vous tourner
aussi vers ces solutions pour la
transition écologique
oui absolument je voudrais ce soir je
cet après midi me faire en fait le
témoin d'un double engagement le premier
un peu par opposition avec les
différentes personnes qui sont autour de
la table c'est que la place des start-up
la place des petites entreprises dans
les processus d'innovation et à chaque
fois qu'une transition nécessite une
innovation technologique la place des
start up est primordial sofinnova ce
final à la mise en place l'a fait depuis
maintenant une quarantaine d'années dans
le domaine des sciences de la vie
essentiellement dans le domaine de la
santé
et juste pour vous donner un exemple si
par hasard et je ne le souhaite pas mais
vous avez un accident cardio vasculaire
cérébral on va vous injecter du tpa et
le tpa c'est l'innovation le le résultat
d'une innovation d'une société de
biotechnologie qui s'appelait genentech
et on était au démarrage delà du
financement de genentech qui a 40 ans
donc on a changé la vie des gens de
certaines façons et là je voudrais
parler du deuxième engagement je parlais
d'un double engagement la deuxième
engagement c'est que la biologie la
connaissance de la biologie les
biotechnologies peuvent un certain
nombre d'industries
être un moteur important de la
transition écologique
alors on va pas agir sur la mobilité
bien entendu on va on a choisi en fait
quatre industries pour laquelle on
investit dans des start-up que sont
l'agriculture
on va reparler de l'agriculture va être
un peu c'est primordial sur la nutrition
que sont la chimie est là et les
matériaux alors plutôt que de faire un
grand spectre en discours je vous
donnais qu'à trois ou quatre exemples le
premier une société qui s'appelle bio
thalys en belgique qui a qui travaillent
sur l'alternative d artane étaient
biologiques au aux pesticides c'est que
les pesticides sont en général ce sont
des molécules de synthèse qui viennent
de la pétrochimie la plupart du temps et
essayer de réfléchir à des passes que
d'utiliser moins de pesticides c'est
bien faire en sorte que les pesticides
parce que jamais on pourra se passer des
pesticides complètement et c'est de
faire en sorte que les pesticides qu'on
utilise soit totalement complet désolé
du farm des termes anglais mais le
respectueux que soit totalement
respectueux de l'environnement c'est
mieux et cette société à partir de
travaux qui avait été développé par un
peu chercheurs belges sur le système
immunitaire des camélidés alors
l'innovation emprunte parfois des
emprunts de faro des chemins de traverse
qui sont en surprenant mais c'est ça
aussi la beauté du système est bien
développement développe des molécules
qui ne présente aucun résidu qui sont
totalement respectueux de
l'environnement et qui permettre de
traiter de au même prix avec la même
efficacité que les produits de synthèse
donc là on en est au terme c'est
l'innovation la société devrait
normalement mettre ce 1er mai est
produit sur le marché des pesticides de
10,6 d'ici deux ans en 2022
et voilà ça c'est à dire les ans le
teint un deuxième deuxième exemple un
deuxième exemple qui et qui fait pas mal
parler de lui c'est le vous savez que
les bouteilles en plastique le ce on
parle beaucoup de ces deux de ses
plastiques qu'on appelle le pays hôte et
le politique est un stade qui est qui
est très difficile qui s'accumulent dans
l'environnement et il ya une société qui
s'appelle avantium à amsterdam qui
il a développé un bio plastique qui ne
s'accumule pas dans dans l'environnement
et à partir de quand des bioplastiques à
partir de déchets agricoles de déchets
agricoles voire à partir de de co2 donc
l'utiliser le gaz carbonique comme
matière première pour fabriquer des
plastiques qui ne vont pas s'accumuler
dans la dans l'environnement
voilà un super challenge que nous avons
financé et on est très contents les
avoir financées même si c'est un combat
de tous les jours
vous êtes des dénicheurs en fait de
bonnes pratiques de bonne solution en
termes de transition écologique est ce
que cette crise joue un rôle
d'accélérateur selon vous dans ce
domaine
la crise du lait vous parlez la crise
d'oka vide on serons nous on nous a
beaucoup m'interroger sur l'accélération
dans le dos de la santé puisque ça reste
70 % de ce qu'on fait mais nous notre
notre horizon notre horizon il est à on
est parmi les rares financier qui avons
un horizon à 7 8 10 ans donc non je ne
peux pas dire que je peux pas dire que
ce soit c'était un accélérateur un
accélérateur des prises de conscience
la prise de conscience d'un certain
nombre d'investisseurs institutionnels
chez qui on va chercher de l'argent pour
pouvoir investir dans des start up est
important oui alors là là là
effectivement on voit une évolution très
nette avec une différenciation très
forte entre les institutionnels qui
reste très allard à l'âge à la retraite
radis les attendait dans les logiques
très traditionnel et puis l'émergence de
dan une nouvelle catégorie
d'investisseurs que ce qu'on appelle les
family offices
parce que dans les familles office on
observe une transition générationnelle
entre les décident des décideurs des
départs envers les enfants et ce sont
les enfants ce sont les jeunes qui qui
qui font qu'ils font marcher le progrès
en ce moment pour vous sylvie janot
cette crise vous incitent-elles
justement à aller plus vite chez dalkia
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ou au contraire vous vous
dites c'est pas le moment faut d'abord
gérer l'urgence c'est bien la crise
alors moi je suis effectivement avant
tout optimiste et je me réjouis aussi
que la transition énergétique se met au
coeur des plans de relance
la crise a été un électrochoc et quand
je suis optimiste moi je rebondis sur ce
que disait chateaubriand il disait
les moments de crise produise un
redoublement de vie chez les hommes et
je crois que on a à la fois
effectivement évidemment des inquiétudes
parce qu'on trouve aujourd'hui le prix
des énergies fossiles le prix du gaz qui
sont extrêmement bas quand on commence à
regarder les anticipations de pi vont se
dire où là on va profiter de cette
énergie à prix bas et on pourrait se
dire ouh là là on va pas on va oublier
un petit peu de décarbonée notre
économie est oublié cette lutte contre
le changement climatique
en fait c'est une seconde crise qui
pourrait arriver et là où je suis très
optimiste c'est qu'on a plein de raisons
d'espérer c'est que en fait la crise
nous a montré qu'on était capable de
mobiliser très vite plein de choses
alors tout d'abord mobiliser des
énergies humaines parce que pendant
cette crise on a vu les personnels de
santé bien sûr mais en deuxième ligne
avait des techniciens par exemple de
chez dalkia qui était dans les hôpitaux
pour gérer la qualité de l'air les
climatisation le chauffage etc
et pas que ghana il y en a eu plein
d'autres et ça y est ça s'est fait en
très peu de temps
en très peu de temps aussi il ya eu des
quantités de personnes qui étaient dans
des bureaux qui se sont mis la télé
travailler et qu'est ce qu'on voit suite
au télétravail quand même une
transformation et un lien avec le
changement climatique on verra ce que ça
donne plus tard mais moins - de
transport moins de monde dans les
voitures vous avez vu ce petit village
du pendjab où finalement subitement il
ya des jeunes qui n'avaient jamais vu ça
qu'ils voient l'himalaya et donc des
transformations des chocs qui arrivent
et qui me donne effectivement des
raisons d'espérer on a également tous
les accords financiers tout
l'accompagnement financier la
mobilisation financière l'accord
européen qui permet à ces
extraordinaires porté par un monsieur
macro madame merkel donc autant de
raisons qui me disent ça doit nous
pousser à accélérer il ya il ya de quoi
faire pour aller sauver des vies parce
que la lutte contre le changement
climatique c'est aussi aller sauver des
vies alors des exemples concrets
on pourrait accélérer alors je vais
évidemment me reporter aussi un peu aux
activités de dalkia il faut regarder on
parle beaucoup dans les énergies
renouvelables de l'électricité en france
globalement l'électricité c'est peu
émettrice de carbone
on oublie que quand on regarde les
consommations d'énergie l'a peu près la
moitié consacrée de la production de
chaleur
quand je dis de la chaleur
et du chauffage de l'eau chaude de la
vapeur industrielle si on commence à
s'intéresser à cette décarbonation là
comment on va faire on va les développer
les réseaux de chaleur alors il ya des
réseaux de chaleur en france déjà on est
assez basse commenté en garde les 6% des
logements à peu près en france sont
chauffés avec des réseaux de chaleur
plutôt près de 70% en suède
vous avez parlé de des énergies
renouvelables on va on va s'apprécier
des énergies renouvelables dick
thermique
on va faire des réseaux de chaleur à
partir de bio bio masse le bois le bois
qui est la première énergie renouvelable
d'ailleurs en france on va aller on peut
faire on peut faire du biogaz et on peut
faire de la récupération d'énergie et ça
c'est très intéressant on peut aller
chercher de la chaleur qui est produite
et là je veux revenir si un thématiques
qui m'est chère l'économie circulaire 1
il ya des par exemple des incinérateurs
de déchets on allait chercher la chaleur
qui est produite par ces incinérateurs
et on va aller chauffer des habitants
ont fait ça sur des sites industriels
un chez psa ya une fonderie à
charleville mézières on récupère cette
chaleur on va chauffer chauffer des
habitants ça c'est extrêmement
intéressant et on est vraiment dans
cette orientation à la fois de de
production du renouvelable et de
l'économie circulaire extrême envers
crieuse puis un deuxième axe qui est
essentiel pour aller lutter contre cette
changement climatique c'est bien
évidemment de travailler sur la
meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme par un bain billoir viens viens
donc on a parlé également c'est comment
on arrive à aller plus loin dans les
économies d'énergie et ça c'est des
choses qui sont assez concrète on peut
le faire assez vite d'ores et déjà
accéléré et nous on pousse évidemment
j'ai là le contrat de performance
énergétique c'est à dire qu'on va aller
s'engager sur des chiffres
je crois que c'est essentiel s'engager
sur des chiffres il ya des acteurs tels
que nous des services énergétiques dix
hommes capables de s'engager de prendre
des risques en disant on va faire moins
10 -20 -30 -40 % l'énergie là j'ai 20
ans je suis en train d'accompagner en
indre-et-loire des lycées collèges il ya
plus de 50 lycées collèges on s'engage à
plus de 30%
quand je dis s'engager c'est à dire que
si le résultat il n'est pas atteint la
paume économique à l'epo d' aller pour
moi voyez ce que je veux dire et donc et
on accompagne des clients et y ont fait
des choses on va aller travailler un peu
justement sur d'isolation sur les
matériels
sur l'efficacité énergétique des
chaudières on va beaucoup travailler sur
le comportement c'est intéressant parce
que la crise a montré qu'on pouvait
bouger dans nos comportements bouger
très vite dans les comportements et donc
faire changer des comportements s'est
aussi accompagnée avec du numérique mais
pour un lycée collège c'est tout
simplement ne pas chauffer le mercredi
le samedi et dimanche et pendant les
vacances scolaires
donc c'est ça vous paraît évident c'est
pas toujours toujours bien orchestre les
bonnes pratiques aux voiliers étaient
très bonnes pratiques et puis il ya
plein d'autres thèmes de l'innovation
qui vont être accélérés l'hydrogène par
exemple voilà je suis intarissable
on a pas finis effectivement de
d'aborder toutes ces questions bertrand
camus avec votre groupe eaux suez on
aborde aussi un des secteurs
stratégiques en termes de lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
comment appréhendez vous cette question
est ce que c'est une responsabilité qui
vous incombent un fardeau c'est
absolument une mission extraordinaire
je pense que tout le monde est conscient
et tous les interlocuteurs que j'ai que
soient les grandes entreprises les
gouvernements qu'on peut pas répéter la
même les mêmes erreurs qu'en 2008 à où
on a refermé le dossier du changement
climatique
en dix ans il fallait relancer
l'économie ce que disait bertrand badré
précédemment depuis en fait rennes s'est
passé jusqu'en 2015 2015 en a signé un
grand accord et depuis 2015 ont fait du
surplace sur l'ensemble de ces de ces
sujets mais faut pas perdre espoir il ya
énormément de possibilités et il faut
aussi prendre conscience qu'on parle
beaucoup co2 beaucoup des sujets
d'atténuation de l'impact mais il faut
pas oublier non plus les questions des
pollutions la question de
l'environnement la question de la
biodiversité parce que tout est dit en
fait c'est ce qu'a démontré démontrer
cette crise donc ça suppose d'investir
effectivement dans ces services
essentiels nous fait d auprès des auprès
de la communauté européenne auprès du
gouvernement français les gouvernements
de l'europe mais aussi dans les temps
les pays dans lesquels nous opérons la
prise de conscience de la nécessité
d'investir sur ces sujets les pays qui
n'ont pas accès à l'eau c'est très
intéressant parce que pendant la crise
on a signé plusieurs contrats
l'ouzbékistan en angola deux projets qui
prenait un petit peu de temps et ça a
été un déclencheur de la mise en oeuvre
des solutions
je pense qu'en europe et en france en
particulier on prend un peu pour
garantir l'ensemble de ses services d'e
on l'a démontré pendant la crise mais il
faut aussi se projeter sur le long terme
parce que les infrastructures
d'aujourd'hui doivent être pensés par
rapport aux enjeux de demain alors des
exemples concrets
vous avez parlé de la start up dans le
dans le plastique pour essayer de
trouver un plastique biodégradable jeu
pas si on peut l'appeler ainsi que ce
qui ne s'accumulent pas la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est à 300 millions de
tonnes de production de plastiques 500
millions de tonnes à l'horizon 2030 et
la plupart fini dans la nature et dans
l'est dans les océans
et donc voilà il faut mettre en place
des schémas de collecte et de
containment comme on dit et on fait
partie d'une alliance pour l'élimination
du déchet plastique avec à la fois les
producteurs de plastique les
utilisateurs et des entreprises comme
nous qu'ils ont maintenant entre deux
collectes on éliminer lyon recycle donc
avec le bois ses objectifs éviter que ça
se retrouve dans la nature que ça pollue
que ça se retrouve dans la chaîne
alimentaire et avec un impact positif
sur le co2 puisque voilà quand on
recycle du pnt on est en économie 70%
émissions de co2 pareil pour le phd je
pourrais aussi parler d'autres flux
comme le papier comme comme le vert si
on parle de l'eau a été très surpris de
retrouver des traces de virus dans les
eaux usées enfin c'est pas une fatalité
alors petite parenthèse il ya aucun
souci avec l'eau potable
c'est très clair c'est éliminer par les
traitements c'est un virus comme les
autres il est éliminé là où il y a accès
à l'eau potable
mais s'ils se retrouvent dans les eaux
usées c'est parce qu'on n'a pas mis en
place les traitements qui existent
aujourd'hui pour éliminer ces virus
comme on pourrait aussi parler des
perturbateurs endocriniens des hormones
des micro plastiques et donc tout ça
doit être prise en compte en plus en se
projetant dans un monde dans lequel il y
aura beaucoup plus de personnes est une
ressource fragilisé par le changement
climatique la scène là qui est à côté
nous c'est moitié moins d'eau en 2040
pendant l'été disons qu'il va falloir
mieux traiter les effluents pour
protéger le
le long du rhône et quand vous dites on
ne le fait pas c'est parce que manque de
moyens manque de vision
c'est une question de priorité vous dire
quand on regarde la transition que
doivent mener tous les secteurs
essentiels pour elle la santé
l'éducation on peut parler de la
sécurité
on peut parler des services essentiels l
environnement dont il ya des besoins en
fait d'investissements dans l'ensemble
de ces deux secteurs en énergie et donc
c'est vraiment une fixation de priorité
est de mettre des désinvestissements sur
ces sujets qui en plus de ça on vend
davantage d'être très souvent des sujets
locaux donc des emplois non
délocalisables
avec de plus en plus d' expertise vous
parlez de start up to d'ailleurs nous
traînons énormément apporté des
innovations dans nos services et puis
qui donne du sens qui est quelque chose
de très important pour les jeunes
générations
merci beaucoup et je me tourne vers vous
à jean marc jancovici pour premières
conclusions de ce premier tour de table
vous avez entendu les engagements des
uns et des autres pierre par pierre on
peut construire comme ça si tout est
mené à bien une décarbonation progressif
de l'économie mais finalement est-ce que
ce sera suffisant
je vais essayer avant de répondre à
cette question de rappeler quelques
données de cadrage du problème auquel on
s'attaque quand je suis né il ya
maintenant beaucoup trop longtemps
la concentration en co2 dans
l'atmosphère augmentait chaque année de
deux millilitres par mètre cube un
accord s'est pas beaucoup 2008 par mètre
cube de co2 sauf qu'ils se trouvent que
le co2 est un opacifiant extrêmement
puissants aux infrarouges émis par la
surface de la planète et ça suffit pour
faire dériver le système climatique et
engendrait ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
le réchauffement donc quand je suis né
s'était un peu moins de 2 par an
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus de 2 par
an entre temps il ya eu la convention
climat avant c'était un peu moins de 2
après si un peu plus de 2 il ya eu
rapport développement durable
avant c'était un peu moins de 2 après
c'est un peu plus de 2 il ya eu l'essor
des énergies renouvelables
avant c'était un peu moins de 2 après
c'est un peu plus de 2 il y a eu la
digitalisation de l'économie avant
c'était un peu moins de 2 après c'est un
peu plus de 2 donc quand vous regardez
l'évolution la concentration en co2 dans
l'atmosphère c'est désespérant pas ce
que vous vous dites que il ne se passe
rien dont crète à thoune berg a raison
de dire c'est pas qu'on en fait pas
assez c'est qu'on fait rien ça aurait
été pire sinon un martien devenons avant
on le faisait avant mon sens on
discutait pas du problème et a augmenté
moins vite
donc non c
donc ça pourrait toujours être pire dans
son esprit mais en pratique
donc ça c'est le côté désespérant le
côté optimiste c'est que pour moi qui
suis donc un vieillard et qui
m'intéresse à ce sujet depuis 20 ans la
table ronde qui a cet après midi ils
n'auraient pas existé il ya dix ans et
je me rappelle très bien qu après la
canicule de 2003 le sujet du climat il a
fait une brève apparition dans les
médias et dans les institutions il
reparti aussi vite qu'il n'est jamais
venu donc on n'a pas vu donc la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça commence à
discuter et commencé il ya des pressions
etc
c'est une bonne nouvelle alors
maintenant si on décide de commencer à
être un peu sérieux sur la question il
ya un chiffre qu'il faut avoir en tête
qui s'appelle -5%
si on veut limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 2 degrés entre l'époque
dite pré industriels car avant qu'on
commence à faire joujou avec les
machines à vapeur 1750 on va dire et
2100 à cause de la très grande durée de
vie du co2 dans l'atmosphère
il faut qu'il faudra plus de dix mille
ans après l'arrêt des émissions pour que
le co2 qu on a rajouté en excès dans
l'atmosphère s'évacue plus de dix mille
ans donc on a affaire à un truc
totalement irréversible à l'échelle des
temps historiques totalement c'est donc
une quantité totale de co2 qu'on met
dans l'atmosphère qui compte si on veut
limiter le réchauffement à 2 degrés il
faut que les émissions planétaires
baisse chaque année 2 5% à partir de
maintenant hors 5% c'est à peu près ce
qu'on va voir en 2020 donc ça venait
bilan finement avec le confinement donc
ça veut dire que la bonne trajectoire de
décarbonation de nos activités
c'est de l'ordre de la baisse
d'émissions que ce que nous avons que
nous avons en 2020 répété chaque année
d'accord et donc une entreprise qui est
aligné 2 degrés est une entreprise qui a
un business plan qui est compatible avec
cette trajectoire de baisse bien sûr
c'est une vision systems
donc c'est pas juste sur le périmètre
propre ça veut dire que tous les flux
dont vous dépendez directement ou
indirectement et donc moi je salue le
plan de catherine dit ouah je le trouve
très ambitieux mais une partie de ces
passagers viennent en avion du japon et
si ses passagers ne sont plus là non
mais je veux dire voilà c'est il faut
bien voir qu'on est dans un système
c'est pas du tout une critique c'est
très difficile d'avoir cette pensée
systémique parce que les entreprises
sortent d'un monde sans limite dans
lequel chacun pouvait raisonner dans son
silo toutes choses égales par ailleurs
d'accord l'espace quand d'occuper soit
n'y avait pas d'effet d'éviction par
rapport à l'espace occupé par les autres
et on rentre dans un monde fini où
chaque croissance chez soi engendre des
effets d'éviction chez les autres
peut pas regarder un d'être on devient
indépendamment de ce que devient la
collective c'est vachement dur comme
exercice intellectuel ans c'est très
très compliqué enfin voilà c'est ça la
données de cadrage
alors il se trouve puisque chacun ici et
là pour dire du bien du même je vais
faire comme tout le monde aux chiffres
project bertrand rigole mais il a fait
partie des parrains de cette de ce bébé
donc au chief project on a décidé on
s'est auto saisie de ce que notre
président aurait dû faire après la crise
et qu'il n'a pas fait quoi qu'on en
pense
qui est de dessiner un plan de
transformation de l'économie française
qui soit compatible avec cette baisse de
5% par an des émissions et qui décrivent
non pas d'où tu dois venir l'argent
parce qu'on s'en fout que ce n'est pas
un sujet l'argent aujourd'hui on en crée
un en appuyant ce retour chariot sur le
clavier de l'ordinateur le sujet les
vraies ressources rares c'est les gens
et les ressources physiques
donc nous on va regarder en fonction de
ses vraies ressources rares qui sont les
gens les emplois et les ressources
physiques ce que les gens voulaient
changer par la vitesse à laquelle vous
voudriez l'échangé les ressources il y
en a plus y en a pas si le niveau de la
seine est deux fois plus bas il ya deux
fois plus de baguettes magiques faire
venir de l'eau le liberia donc le la
manière dont on va penser ce plan c'est
ça c'est sous cette compte cette double
contrainte et on va essayer de rendre
notre copie pour dans quelques mois et
c'est exactement ce cadre là dans lequel
on s'est mis pour voir ce qu'on
arriverait en sortir et malheureusement
quoi qu'on en dise n'est pas du tout
comme ça que le l'état français envisage
son plan de relance parce que parce
qu'il ne fait pas d'abord parce qu'il
n'a pas compris pour les maltraiter si
vous faisiez le passé un test de
connaissances au gouvernement français
vous assurez vous auriez le même niveau
de connaissance qu'à l'école primaire
enfin je verse et c'est sur le sujet du
climat et d'énergie les plus couverts de
boue la fenêtre d'opportunité
ressortez ce que je suis en train de
dire dans une semaine ce sera prêt quand
même donc le et on peut pas si vous
connaissez pas le problème à traiter
vous taper au hasard dans les solutions
si vous demandez à un médecin de vous
donner un médicament alors qui sait pas
ce que vous avez d'accord vous êtes
juste une voix derrière une tenture noir
la probabilité pour qu'il trouve le bon
traitement et comme assez faible alors
justement vous avez une transition toute
trouvée sur le rôle des pouvoirs publics
dans cette thématique des changements
climatiques vous l'évoquez sigeano le
green deal au niveau européen le plan
aussi qu'on attend en france disait pour
la rentrée le rôle de la réglementation
est ce que vous dites j'aimerais
jancovici ça peut pour les entreprises
des uns et des autres être un effet
avoir un effet dopant bien sûr les
familles et noir malgré tout bien sûr je
veux bien qu'il y ait de l'hélicoptère
monnaie et comme on dit qui débarque
avec la crise il cite à fait vrai mais
comme je le disais c'est des
investissements qui sont lourds pour les
entreprises en revanche là où je trouve
que bertrand avait un point c'est sur
les questions d'externalités parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ait une vision
économique des projets de transition
écologique dans lesquels on s'est très
très mal calculé les externalités
positives de ces projets et je pense que
là il ya un vrai sujet de pouvoir mieux
expliquer de pouvoir mieux les mettre en
lumière alors bien entendu sur le
transport public urbain
il ya un rôle fondamental à jouer
puisque je le disais on consommer 60
fois moins de co2 quand vous prenez un
transport public quand vous prenez votre
voiture individuelle et le pire du pire
ce serait d'arriver dans une situation
qui est plus ou moins chez dark et je
peux pas faire de la prophétie auto
réalisatrice mais aujourd'hui la ratp à
paris a retrouvé à peine 50 % de son
trafic preco vide
donc ça veut dire que non seulement
certains comportements sont en train de
changer mais surtout que on a fait moins
30 tp +30 la voiture en ile de france
actuellement
donc c'est très inquiétant il faut
absolument évidemment donc nous on prend
nos responsabilités on a fait une
révolution copernicienne en réinvitant
en investissement très lourd sur la
propreté la nive de nouvelles
technologies ont nébuleuse tous les
soirs les bus de la ratp
c'était quelque chose qu'on a mis en
place en un mois qui revient à faire
d'anne immunisation 20 microgrammes de
produits virucide des choses qui
n'existaient pas il ya encore deux mois
si on veut aussi pour vous avez bien sûr
je voudrais le budget de l'an dernier 90
millions deux cent dix millions cette
année donc sur un secteur dont les
marges sont déjà très compris mais il va
falloir encaisser le choc de tout cela
mais c'est pour moi une externalités
positives parce que il faut à tout prix
congas
une matraque tivité des transports en
commun et on n'a pas le choix donc ça
c'est un point absolument fondamental il
est nécessaire je partage tout à fait
votre avis le green deal est là mais il
va falloir encapsulé dans le green deal
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses le
commissaire breton a proposé aux 6-14
segments industriels j'allais dire sur
lequel la commission va bas va
travailler et dans lesquels évidemment
le secteur de la mobilité a toute sa
place
il va falloir effectivement que du côté
alors ça a commencé avec l'aéronautique
et l'automobile
il est effectivement normale est grand
temps que nous mettions en place un
certain nombre de mesures pour le
transport public urbain on y travaille
avec nos autorités de tutelle que ce
soit d'ailleurs le secrétariat d'état
aux transports ou bercy
il est vraiment important qu'on soit
capable d'aller en en capsules et nous
demande dans ce green deal européen ce
serait complètement incompréhensible que
le transport public urbain soit soit
tenu à l'écart de tous alors ça il ya un
premier effort ce qui intervint peu d'un
premier effort qui a été fait dans le
plfr 3 puisqu'il ya un remboursement de
versements mobilité qui engage et leurs
1 400 millions 425 millions sur l'île de
france
évidemment l'enjeu est beaucoup plus
vaste que ça valérie pécresse a parlé de
deux milliards 6 parce qu'il ya toute la
question de la perte des recettes
commerciales qu'a été engrangés pendant
le confinement à dire que la machine a
tourné à plein puisque typiquement comme
vous on était tout à fait un service
essentiel à la nation on a permis
j'allais dire aux gens de la
distribution alimentaire ou aux
hospitaliers on avait d'ailleurs fait un
programme dédié pour les hospitaliers de
bus de tournée et donc j'allais dire on
a été vraiment rendez-vous de la crise
et il faut maintenant évidemment que on
soit au rendez-vous de la presse donc ne
nous oubliez pas si je vous entendu
absolument fait je crois pas qu'on sera
oublié parce qu'on est quand même assez
essentiel dans le dispositif
on travaille là dessus si jehanno est ce
que pour vous aussi
ces plans de relance qui vont aussi
avoir une traduction à la rentrée sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
notamment qui peut être un nouveau
chantier est ce que les minions mignard
qui peuvent être injectées sont
essentiels oui la raison la raison pour
laquelle et pour les politiques
publiques sont essentielles c'est
simplement que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure les prix
des énergies fossiles en particulier du
gaz sont très bas et donc ya pas de
modèle économique
tous spontanée qui favorise le fait que
je vais être subitement faire une grande
rénovation du bâtiment ou que je vais
plutôt utiliser l'énergie de la mer pour
faire mon réseau de chaleur que youtube
riga a souri et donc on donc il faut
compenser il faut compenser donc on a on
a des subventions tout simplement qui
forme de prix implicite du carbone si on
peut le dire comme ça donc sur les
réseaux de chaleur c'est le fonds
chaleur
alalala ppe d'ailleurs prévoit
d'augmenter son fonds chaleur pour
accompagner ce développement des
énergies renouvelables sur les
territoires en local sont des projets
très locaux revenir un peu sur le rôle
le rôle du local il semble avant sa
table-ronde aussi et donc des politiques
publiques qui sont très essentiel sur
l'efficacité énergétique c'est pareil
c'est quand si vous aussi vous allez pas
spontanément économiser si votre
investissement et par complètement
rentabilisé au bout de x temps un vous
changez votre chaudière votre isolation
c'était à vous regarder un petit peu et
donc bah si c'est il faut des aides pour
aujourd'hui enclenché économiquement les
choses denis lucquin sur cette question
de la réglementation est ce que pour une
entreprise comme la vôtre fonds
d'investissement fonds de capital risque
c'est important alors plus pour les
sociétés dans lequel on n'investit que
pour les forêts pour pour nous et la
réglementation est un environnement dans
lequel on se démène l'une des grandes
caractéristiques des start-up cessé
d'être flexible de s'adapter très vite à
leur environnement et je dois dire que
dans le domaine je vous prends un
exemple dans celui que j'ai cités tout à
l'heure dans le domaine de ddv aux
pesticides la réglementation américaine
est beaucoup plus précise net clair on
connaît le chemin pour arriver sur le
marché par rapport à une réglementation
européenne comme moi j'entends par les
gens parlant des green deal j'entends
parler de deux choses de subventions que
c'est très bien mais les sociétés quand
on va investir dans une société belge sa
stratégie de développement va consister
à aller aux états unis car ça sera les
aux états unis qu'elle pourra mettre son
marché sont produits sur le marché le
plus rapidement possible dans les
moindre coût possible
et ça c'est absolument fondamental
dans les toutes les sociétés qui ont
investi et on a remarqué ce shift entre
un grand discours dans ce qui se passe
en europe mais qui n'est pas suivie de
faits concrets et une réglementation qui
est plus favorable plus favorable au
développement de produits respectueux de
l'environnement s'étaient unis c'est
surprenant par rapport à l'image que
peut avoir ce pays d'enhaut dans le le
collectif mais voilà peut-être un mot
aussi de l'investissement vous l'évoquez
ce sont des investissements qui sont
lourds qui sont conséquents est-ce que
malgré tout dans cette période de crise
économique
ces investissements sont ou peuvent être
ralentis 4 ben non je pense que
justement ce serait la grande erreur il
faudrait pas rajouter à la crise
économique et sociale une crise de
l'investissement honnêtement pour faire
repartir en plus c'est de
l'investissement qui a quitté flèche
franchement plusieurs objectifs à la
fois sur la transition à la fois sur le
fait qu on fait travailler des filières
industrielles très conséquente la ratp
c'est aujourd'hui 65 mille salariés dans
le groupe mais nos emplois induits et
indirects ses 128 milles le pipe générer
ces 8 milliards l'équivalent de celui de
la guadeloupe
on a deux milliards et demi d'achat en
ce moment vu la politique
d'investissement qu'on a par an donc on
tire toute la filière et je pense que du
coup il ya vraiment un triple intérêt à
le faire maintenant parce qu'il ya une
opportunité finalement extra une prise
de conscience une opportunité
extraordinaire de le faire et il faut
surtout pas rajouter
j'allais dire une crise de
l'investissement et à la crise
économique et sociale se serait ce
serait catastrophique et dans le dans
les transports ça va être un cas concret
tout à fait intéressant de suivre donc
je pense que non là au contraire il faut
foncer
bertrand camus est ce que vous vous
posez des questions en ce moment vous
arbitrez vous dit bon on peut pas tout
faire il faut prioriser est-ce que la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
peut passer un peu au second plan
oui j'ai tout à l'heure ce serait me
disais catherine ce serait vraiment une
une erreur fondamentale de toute façon
on fait on peut jouer à la roulette
russe encore pendant quelques années
mais le changement climatique il est là
les événements se succèdent
moi j'étais en poste à new york 110
super storm coût 60 milliards de dollars
on a eu on est opérateur au chili
sécheresse depuis cinq ans sur le grand
santiago
les événements climatiques à cannes 2016
et de nouveau cette année
donc la réalité du changement climatique
est là et et ces événements vont
continuer à se répéter et donc si on au
service essentiel que ce soit la gestion
de l'eau des inondations du déchet on
voit bien qu'il faut qu'il faut agir
donc dans leur au contraire c'est
profitons d'une certaine façon de
l'opportunité que nous donne ses plans
de relance pour au contraire mettre un
coup d'accélérateur
quand vous entendez jean marc jancovici
qui vous dit il faudrait quand même
reproduire ce qu'on a vécu là avec trois
mois de confinement pour arriver et
tenir nos objectifs
ah mais moi je suis totalement en ligne
peut-être pas sur le confinement mais
sur le fait qu'il faut toujours être
ambitieux on est depuis des années dans
une logique où on restreint les
ambitions on voit on travestit la
réalité par manque de moyens je crois
qu'il faut être clair sur le diagnostic
clair sur les objectifs alors vous aussi
aider chateaubriand j'aime bien coluche
qui fait toujours mettre la barre haut
pour pouvoir passer en dessous sans se
baisser et après mobiliser les moyens et
surtout au delà des réglementations et
des moyens financiers
vous avez deux éléments il faut croire
en l'innovation des entreprises
regardez toutes les aventures humaines
la capacité à baisser le coût moyen à
partir du moment où on s'est fixé un
objectif la logistique suit et puis
faire confiance aux gens on a des
citoyens qui sont intelligents
les gens se mobilisent et ensemble
encore une fois y aura pas une solution
par un des acteurs mobilisés ensemble on
peut atteindre des objectifs très
ambitieux jean marc jancovici direction
peut-être ce qui vient d'être dit je
vais joindre les deux questions la
première c est ce qu il faut de la
réglementation évidemment vous
considérez que c'est une très bonne
chose que quand vous empruntez une route
n'en déplaise à d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas le temps de conduire à
gauche trouvé ça très bien vous trouvé
ça très bien que la fréquence occupé par
france info n'est pas le droit d'être
occupé par quelqu'un d'autre qui
auraient envie d'occuper la même
fréquence donc évidemment qu'il faut de
la réglementation est en fait l'état ne
sert qu'à ça
il sert à faire des règles du jeu la
question c'est qu'il fasse les bonnes
donc oui il faut de la réglementation
mais il est du devoir de l'état de faire
la bonne réglementation et donc ça
renvoie à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il est aujourd'hui c'est
inadmissible aujourd'hui je prononce le
mot inadmissible que dans la sphère
politico administratives on n'est pas
une idée claire du problème à traiter
c'est devenu une faute j'insiste le sur
la partie investissement
en fait quand on regarde la transition
ça va être un retour à une société où
l'investissement occupe une part
beaucoup plus importante du pib que
aujourd'hui en gros aujourd'hui
d'investissement formation brute de
capital fixe on veut être aux alentours
de 20% du pib comme il faudrait revenir
à 40 donc c'est un monde dans lequel les
gens vont moins consommer mais dans
lequel on va plus investis et c'est
absolument indispensable parce qu'on a
besoin de transformer le monde dans
lequel on vit
on a besoin de transformer les villes d
faire dégonfler un peu pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles
on a besoin de changer la structure
productive dans un certain nombre
d'endroits donc on a vraiment besoin
d'investir est effectivement pendant un
temps on achètera moins de chaussettes
et moines plats surgelés pas très grave
dernier point est ce qu'il faut de la
contrainte pour les entreprises
évidemment les entreprises 9 que sous la
contrainte donc vous avez cité ma
casquette de président du chili projet
que je suis aussi un start over me
plaisent à donner ligue 1 puisque j'ai
fondé une boîte ya treize ans à 13 ans
je patiente encore un starter d'un vieux
starter
il fait je dire le monde privé et celui
que je fréquente tous les jours on y
pense que sous la contrainte en banque
privée la contrainte de ses concurrents
la contrainte de la réglementation la
contrainte d'avoir les bons qui passa
qui partent ou viennent pas chez vous et
c'est que sous la contrainte
donc il faut vraiment pas avoir peur et
au construire aujourd'hui qu'il est
légitime dans ce pays une entreprise
meurent parce qu'elle n'est pas capable
de satisfaire à une contrainte qui est
de contribuer à la solidarité sociale
si vous n'êtes pas capable de payer aux
charges du staff il suez n'est plus
capable de payer l'urssaf sur et se
dépose le bilan et on considère que
c'est normal que c'est une règle du jeu
normal je ne vois aucune raison pour
laquelle il en irait pas de même sur la
solidarité environnementale
donc aujourd'hui les instances
patronales pousse des cris d'orfraie à
chaque fois qu'il est question de leur
faire payer un pour dix mille de leurs
résultats nets sur une meilleure prise
en compte des enjeux environnementaux
c'est une blague je veux dire il faut
pas avoir peur d'y laisser la vie
normale des entreprises sylvie giono a
rejoint ce que je disais sur le fait que
les modèles économiques y sont souvent
imposés alors je pense qu'effectivement
hiver d'investissement c'est à dire que
la transition énergétique va générer des
projets dans les territoires et est
d'ailleurs ces projets qui sont
extrêmement locaux vont générer d'emploi
local non délocalisables donc voilà
c'est un argent un enjeu fort aussi pour
la relance la contrainte vous le disait
jean marc jancovici c'est aussi la
contrainte de la société civile des ong
c'est important aussi ça peut-être fait
bouger quelques consciences
est ce que vous vous la sentez cette
pression au quotidien cité jehanno oui
c'est important cette question parce que
je plusieurs reprises là j'ai utilisé le
mot du local il réussir à la transition
énergétique aussi si elle est acceptée
un an
on veut pas revenir sur ce sujet des dg
les jaunes mais pour pour faire
comprendre nos projets moi je par
exemple à lyon j'ai que soit la plus
grosse chaufferie biomasse public de
france il y en a qui peuvent venir
ouhlala du bois ça abîme des forêts
taira pas du tout elle est la forêt est
en croissance en france mais personne ne
le sait on va couper des arbres en
proximité on est à moins de 100 km on
les amène on achemine là
l'installation est totalement rigoureuse
dans son fonctionnement a été ramené en
dessous de toutes les normes et on fait
des énergies renouvelables de la chaleur
renouvelable pour aller chausser des
habitants donc cette pédagogie là elle
nécessite aussi de voilà de
l'acceptabilité et tout le tissu local
nous aide évidemment là la collectivité
territoriale qui est notre délégataire
délégation de service public qui arrive
à faire un projet avec un acteur de type
privé tels que nous et puis derrière il
ya plein plein de partenaires et il ya
évidemment aussi des atouts le tissu
associatif qui va être là pour nous
aider et faire accepter ce projet on va
y trouver les logiques économiques on va
retrouver de la compétitivité aussi dans
la production a le prix de la chaleur il
va aller chercher des prix qui font que
ben on va aller se raccorder au réseau
de chaleur
d'ailleurs on arrive à le faire là
encore parce que le fonds chaleur piloté
par l'ademe nous nous nous y est vous
voyez que c'est tout un écosystème qui
permet la réussite de ces projets qui
nécessitent à la fois de
l'investissement et et voilà et si on
est pas on n'arrive pas à faire cette
inclusion on n'arrivera pas à faire
cette transition énergétique aussi
catherine gay loi oui je pensais en vous
écoutant je ne peux qu'approuver on a
lancé un projet d'économie circulaire
dans les quartiers du 12 avec le siège
de la ratp dans le xiième tue pas
complètement par hasard dans le xiième
et dans le xiiie qui s'appelle le
quartier des deux rives puisqu'on à la
scène mieux et on s'est mis dans un
écosystème avec toutes les avec la ville
de paris tous les pme les services
publics etc
et c'est à ses performances alors qu'on
a fait on a fait des gestions des
déchets qui soit entre guillemets
écologiquement responsable les
transports aussi contribué à la ratp
apporte son point là-dessus et c'est
vrai que ce genre d'initiative est
excellent parce que d'abord c'est une
remontée de terrain d'expérience pour
nook et qui a de la valeur
maman et puis ça montre que quand les
acteurs sont alignés alors c'est un
petit bout de jancovic djokovic fait à
tout petit bout de femme mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même utile et
nous par exemple ça nous a fortement
motivés exemple je sais que je suis à
côté de bertrand canu donc
attention à ce que je dis la ratp le
risque 99% de ces déchets aujourd'hui
donc cédé bien ces expériences on arrive
à nous mêmes après en tirer des process
qui sont apprenants qui motive les
équipes et je voudrais juste dire ça
pour attirer des jeunes talents
aujourd'hui est bien quand vous avez un
vrai sujet une vraie stratégie
d'engagement environnemental pas du
blabla de rapports annuels rs mais
vraiment quelque chose de concret où
vous pouvez apporter des preuves c'est
très très parlant aux jeunes et du coup
on arrive à attirer les talents dans le
service public actuellement dans des
entreprises comme la ratp parce qu'on
est crédible sur notre politique
environnementale donc ça je pense que
pour l'avenir aussi c'est assez
réconfortant une petite note d'optimisme
je pense que les jeunes ça leur parle
beaucoup je voulais qu'on parle qu'on
aborde pour cette session 3 quelques
questions qui nous arrive
cette session 3 affronter les
changements climatiques celle d'edmond
peut être vouloir trouver des solutions
franco-françaises un problème mondial
n'est-il pas une utopie bertrand camus
je ne pense pas parce qu'en fait on a
quand même un pays qui par sa taille
quand même des entreprises
multinationales internationale c'est
peut-être pas un mot qui est très
populaire mais en faisant partie qui au
contraire a pu grâce à l'expérimentation
à l'innovation et la résolution de cas
concrets sur le territoire national à la
pointe de la technologie modèle de
gouvernance modèle contractuel a pu se
développer à l'international et à portée
d apporter des solutions à l'échelle
globale donc oui aujourd'hui ça peut
sembler être un effort qui est minime au
niveau de 2 des émissions de la planète
mais c'est ce qui nous permet
aujourd'hui d'être pertinent en inde
être pertinent en chine d'être pertinent
en afrique et c'est ce que viennent
chercher nos clients pour résoudre leurs
problèmes donc dans leur au contraire on
doit être à la pointe doit être à la
pointe on doit être devant les autres
pour embarquer ce mouvement et nous on
est complètement convaincu que la france
peut être le champion de la transition
environnementale
jean marc jancovici de votre fenêtre
coûterait que la france justement et est
plutôt bien engagé dans toutes ses
branches pour que à une carte
traoré nerfs à jouer et je suis un peu
triste de voir qu'aujourd'hui on la joue
pas encore assez d'abord je souscris
totalement ce qui vient d'être dit et il
faut rappeler que l'homme est un animal
mimétique que c'est comme ça qu'on élève
nos enfants et donc l'idée que si nous
on trouve des trucs intelligents à faire
le reste de la planète va nous regarder
les bras croisés je n'y crois pas une
seconde
ensuite on a un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques de premier rang dans notre
pays qui sont des multinationales
donc quand vous êtes une multinationale
vous exportez c'est à dire que ce que
vous faites chez vous qui marche bien
vous allez chercher à le faire chez d
autres
donc c'est exactement ce qui vient
d'être dit il ya un effet tache d'huile
qui fait que l'assiette pertinente des
émissions sur laquelle raisonnée c'est
pas un pour cent c'est plus que ça
ensuite le dernier point c'est qu'il
faut faire le pari de pascal à l'envers
c'est à dire si tout le monde reste les
bras croisés on est sûr de tous y passer
donc c'est donc la seule la seule
opportunité qu'on est
c'est de se lancer en se disant que là
il ya une chance que ça réussisse dans
l'argument qui vient d'être révoqué et
un argument qui enterre de gaulle ils
avaient tort d'être pas comme les autres
c'est de partir à londres
il aurait dû faire comme tout le monde
et c'est à dire tranquille dans son coin
n'ont pas beaucoup de gens qui pensent
ça aujourd'hui donc le cet argument de
20% il est totalement spéciaux y tient
pas sur le la partie jeunes moi je
rejoins alors pourquoi est ce que c'est
une chance qu'on a deux pays il se
trouve que la france est un des seuls
pays communiste au monde
un vrai pays communiste on est donc on
adore la planification or on a un
problème de long terme et à grosses
mailles et il se trouve qu'en france un
des traits du génie français on n'a pas
de 150 mais on en a quelques uns c'est
d'être capable d'être très bon dans la
planification des grands systèmes
complexes
c'est un de nos très historique très
fort or il se trouve que le problème
auquel on a affaire est un indémodable
problèmes d'optimisation sous contrainte
qui demandent de bien gérer les grands
systèmes complexes
donc c'est une chance pour nous foncer
tout il faut faire des plans à 10,15 à
avoir la trouille faut y aller et comme
comme il vient dé dit en mettant la
barre le plus haut possible
pourquoi facilement passer dessous
beaucoup mais mais mais c'est une chance
parce que si on attend on va tous être
cuit comme des poulets ça n'a aucun
intérêt
l'intérêt une question qui nous vient
aussi de célia b on a un petit peu
évoquée mais comment initier un tournant
politique en faveur de la transition
écologique et s'imposer comme précurseur
lorsque la performance économique reste
l'outil principal de la concurrence
mondiale
si janot ça vous inspire quoi je crois
qu'on a répondu d'ores et déjà c'est à
dire que là on revient au rôle des
politiques publiques un poil mon panier
qu'on pour accompagner tout cela parce
que effectivement si on aujourd'hui on
aurait tous peut-être envie de consommer
les énergies carbonées et c'est quand
même pas ça le sujet donc voilà et
peut-être en complément je crois que la
bible m'exprime devant un expert québec
aujourd'hui pour les entreprises quand
vous regardez alors je m'exprime en tant
qu'ancien en ancien dirigeant
d'entreprise privée un pas de la ratp je
tiens pas à dire je vais privatiser la
ratp
j'ai eu assez de problèmes comme ça
depuis quelques semaines mais les fonds
et viège est aujourd'hui les fonds qui
regarde la performance environnementale
des entreprises deviennent absolument
clé toutes les grandes entreprises de
l'énergie ou d'autres d'ailleurs le
savent il y a un vrai un break bonis
accordés à ces entreprises donc même
jali dix ans de façon très prosaïque il
ya un vrai intérêt l'économique n'est
pas forcément antinomiques de la
performance environnementale bien au
contrat il faut casser ce genre de
commandite de raisonnement c'est
vraiment le raisonnement du du
rétroviseur de l'avant ouais merci un
camion sur beaucoup des exemples
concrets
nous gérons ce soit dans l'eau dans le
déchet ce qu'on se rend compte qu'il
couchait sur petit la superposition de
l'ancien système et le nouveau système
est en fait ce qui manque c'est la
capacité à investir pour passer d'un
système à l'autre
un exemple tout bête si vous voulez
favoriser le tri à la source
il faut ramasser le moins souvent
possible la poubelle noir parce que tout
le monde du country mieux ces déchets
pour essayer de réduire au minimum la
fraction à conserver chez lui ça sur
l'angleterre ça c'est aux états unis ça
ne se fait pas à paris c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi notre manière les nadj
c'est-à-dire d'inciter par mais des
petits jeux d'aider des récompenses des
mécanismes qui permettent de passer d'un
système à l'autre mais en n'oubliant
jamais que derrière les activités qu'on
considère un peu du passé il ya des
hommes des femmes et le travail des
joueurs bons sur dix sur le commentaire
de catherine il faut absolument
accompagner socialement cette mutation
sinon on crée d'antagonisme et
hélas désespère à sion avec les plans de
suppressions de postes effectivement
dans des filières en difficulté il ya un
enjeu de formation pour tous ses
personnels denis lucquin est ce que
l'opposition et économique et
environnemental c'est effectivement du
passé pour vous aussi
au contraire c'est l'engagement que
c'est l'engagement qu'ont appris en
essayant de lever les fonds qui soient
dédiés à cette industrie
j'aurais revenir sur une question sur
l'action précédente concernant le 1% à
la place de la france les les
entrepreneurs lorsqu'ils créent leur
entreprise lorsqu'ils créent leur start
up ont par définition un esprit qui est
complètement global la dimension
française n'existe pas chez eux
et lorsque l'on créé une société à paris
on sait très bien que le concurrent
principal sera probablement à san diego
et san francisco
et c'est celui qui aura la meilleure
technologie la meilleure propriété
industrielle et qui va être capable de
lever suffisamment d'argent pour faire
sur son développement
qui va gagner donc notre compétition
elle est d'abord et avant tout
international et est-ce que la france a
une chance dans cette compétition la
réponse est oui parce qu'elle a une
recherche académique de très bonne
qualité et en ayant une enregistrés
chaque année mais de très bonne qualité
c'est le ferment sur lesquelles on va
créer des entreprises
donc ça c'est notre vie c'est notre vie
de tous les jours alors on ne fait pas
qu'en france c'est vrai mais la france
très net avantage de ce côté là j'ai
envie aussi de vous poser la question du
gain sur la compensation carbone une
taxe à la production et à l'importation
sur le carbone mais compensée par une
diminution d'autant de la tva permet de
faire changer dit-il rapidement les
comportements de tous sans impacter les
plus pauvres est ce que cette taxe
carbone ça peut être une solution
bertrand camus il va bien falloir
trouver alors qu est ce qu on appelle ça
taxes redevances il va bien falloir
trouver un mécanisme qui fasse payer
celui qui pollue pour pouvoir investir
dans les projets justement un soin de
compensation soit de transition dont
nous avons parlé par les prussiens
d'entreprise qu'il veut dit oui tout à
fait encore une fois l'augmentation
bâton carottes 1 pénalité incentive et
puis innovation c'est quand même comme
ça que l'on avance donc oui il faut que
ce schéma rentre alors après est-ce que
c'est aux frontières de l'europe
beaucoup de débats autour de ces sujets
mais clairement il nous faut un
mécanisme de ce type qui s'est déjà nos
voix il faut des mécanismes sans oublier
le fait qu' on doit avoir une transition
énergétique acceptable qui est accepté
par tous donc voilà il faut trouver les
mécanismes et là ça rejoint évidemment
ce sujet de la politique publique
mais c'est vrai que moment donné voilà
il faut inciter et faire en sorte qu'on
a est vraiment sur l'ailé et politiques
vertige et eux les choix les projets
vertueuse dont on a parlé jean marc
jancovici lui est favorable également
vous pensez que ça peut vraiment faire
bouger des choses qu'on fera moi je
redis on fera rien bouger sans carotte
bâton pour reprendre l'expression qu'il
a dit et ce qu'il faut c'est pas créer
du désespoir dire que quand on met les
gens en tomber une contrainte aux gens
il faut qu'ils aient une alternative
donc si vous montez le prix des
cigarettes vous avez une alternative qui
est d'arrêter de fumer
si vous avez besoin de votre voiture
parce que vous n'êtes pas à paris mais
dans un endroit dans lequel n'y a pas de
transports en commun que vous avez 25
kilomètres à faire on les à votre
travail qui les pieds dans hors de
question vous abandonnez votre travail
parce que vous avez pas les 1 6 6 le
carburant coûte suffisamment cher pour
que vous fassiez que 23 km vous n'allez
pas les faire et faire les 2 restants à
pied donc le la question quand on
commence à mettre une contrainte et
celle de la planification de
l'alternative j'en reviens au grand mot
dans cette affaire qui est le mot de
planification on ne s'en sortira jamais
si on planifie pas après la taxe est
beaucoup plus efficace paradoxalement
pour les entreprises que pour les
particuliers parce que les entreprises
peuvent embaucher des armées de
consultants bardé de tableur excel qui
vont leur faire tout un tas de calcul de
retour sur investissement pour voir à
quel niveau où se situe le seuil de
douleur pour passer d'une alternative à
une autre donc en fait les signaux prix
sont beaucoup plus efficaces dans le
domaine professionnel et je prends un
exemple qui est bien connu c'est celui
de la production électrique en grande
bretagne avec une taxe sur le co2
électrique en grande bretagne ils se
sont débarrassés du charbon en un peu
plus de dix ans qu'ils ont remplacés par
du gaz qui aimait deux fois moins alors
chez eux c'est une très bonne idée chez
nous remplacer le nucléaire par du gaz
serait une très mauvaise idée le dis
tout de suite mais donc ça dépend de
nous devons pas mais ils ont fait ça
notamment parce que les industriels ils
leur ont donné la règle du jeu à l'avant
s'il dort on dit ça va monter
progressivement et c'était pas un prix
très élevé mais le consultant avec son
tableur excel a dit à un moment ça va
être plus intéressant pour vous
de passer au gaz donc ça peut être
quelque chose de très puissant dans mon
industriels à condition que ce soit
planifiée et comprennent clairement où
on va dans le domaine du grand public
s'il n'y a pas les dispositifs
d'accompagnement qui vont avec
il se passe ce qui s'est passé avec les
gilets jaunes parce que vous avez un
sentiment qu'on vous indique pas la
porte de sortie donc c'est c'est bien de
mettre en place des incitations
économiques mais il faut être très
vigilant sur le fait que la porte de
sortie elle soit accessible et bien lieu
d'éclairer donc avec des mécanismes de
compensation pour les plus modestes
on va pas se rentrer dans le débat
technique aujourd'hui parce qu il ya un
milliard de manière de faire non mais
vous pouvez faire plein de plein de
manières vous pouvez par exemple dire
que tous les gens qui aujourd'hui ont
des voitures qui consomment 6 litres
vous allez leur subventionner l'achat
d'une voiture qui consomme 2 litres en
réglementant par ailleurs les émissions
phares la consommation des véhicules
neufs vendus en france de telle sorte
que y en ait beaucoup plus de
disponibles à la vente
c'est une manière de faire qui passent
pas nécessaire pourrait taxer la voiture
plutôt que taxer le carburant vous
pouvez ne plus considérer comme
défiscalisables toutes les voitures de
société qui consomme plus d'enfants il
ya un milliard parce que c'est 40 % des
achats neufs
il ya un milliard de manière de faire
donc on va pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques aujourd'hui cédé 10 et des
boulons ça le point important c'est
encore une fois que les gens sachent où
on va quand on leur dit qu'il va y avoir
une peine merci beaucoup pour tout ces
échanges très nourris très riche
bertrand badré je vous donne ma parole
pour quelques mots de synthèse de
conclusions sur ce qu'on peut retenir de
ces échanges alors c'est à la fois
extrêmement simple de résumer en
quelques mots en disant ça fait du bien
alors que j'ai rentré un peu dans le
détail pourquoi ça ne l'est du bien moi
d'abord parce que c'était une discussion
qui était très enthousiasmante
on n'a pas fait preuve de cynisme de
fatalisme etc
par ailleurs on a tenu les délais chez
les gens n'ont pas trop parler ce qui
permet d'avoir une vraie discussion je
savais que j'ai quelques heures de vol
avec le cercle et c'est une des tables
rondes des plus efficaces que j'ai vu
donc ça ça ça fait du bien alors
quelques points en synthèse jean-marc a
rappelé les enjeux en disant voilà c'est
5% par an de baisse des émissions ça
fait un kobe de parents ces voix là
c'est sérieux c'est réel et l'italie ont
peu l'étaler m'effacer en tout cas c'est
pas on n'est pas dans l'anecdote
deuxièmement il faut qu'on reconnaisse
qu on a fait du surplace depuis quelques
années je crois que c'est l'expression
de bertrand worth que tu as plus le
choix de la roulette russe vendu on va
essayer peut-être qu'on va gagner encore
un tour et puis un jour prendre à la
balle mais ne sera fait pas moi donc
alors que le changement climatique ça a
été rappelé et déjà aujourd'hui c'est
des rails trop chaussée les effets des
catastrophes naturelles etc septembre
donc on n'est pas en train de pallanne
hypothétique future cdc déjà aujourd'hui
l' approche systémique allée centrale
mais les difficiles alors elle est
centrale
à double titre d'abord parce que je
crois bertrand l'a dit les sujets sont
liés c'est ce que j'avais dit dans mes
propos introductif et ensuite qu'il faut
avoir une pensée du système et que c'est
absolument clé pour la réglementation
pour les remèdes qu'on veut trouver pour
ce qu'on veut faire pour la mobilisation
des gens etc
on voit la question d'économie
circulaire c'est pas juste une question
technique c'est aussi une question de
comportement alors et quelques principes
qui ont été posées
catherine avait dit dès son introduction
il faut être concret et concrets précis
il faut s'engager il faut rendre compte
pas de blabla je pense qu'on a eu des
gens n'y croient plus je pense le temps
de la responsabilité sociale on met dans
un rapport annuel de quelques phrases
c'est bien c'était une étape mais je
pense que marc andré et on va voir des
preuves d'amour en deuxièmement il faut
reconnaître que ça a un coût un coût
financier un coût humain de nos
comportements
il faut pas se raconter d'histoires il
ya pas une baguette magique qui fait que
du jour au lendemain on passe d'un
univers à un autre et la clé ça va être
un investissement ça c'est un point que
je retiens qu'elle qui est essentiel il
faut maintenir l'investissement
probablement l'augmenter il faut garder
le cap et s'arrêter je crois que le v10
ce serait ce serait du suicide
il faut savoir innover là aussi innover
c'est pas juste le penseur de rodin qui
dit tiens j'ai une idée c'est tout un
système un écosystème d est ce que denis
a rappelé sur les différences entre
systèmes européens et américains vivant
aux etats unis je le vois effectivement
important je pense qu'il faut il faut il
faut garder ça à l'esprit et compter
aussi sur une poussée des plus jeunes
enfin je pense qu'à une culture de
l'innovation de la start up etc qui est
probable en plus répandue aujourd'hui il
faut penser au local moi je vois sylvie
dalal rappelé l'innovation vient aussi
du local il faut prendre appui
donc sur ces nouvelles générations il
faut aussi alors j'ai bien aimé on est
au cercle des économistes la dernière
discussion sur le nudge les incitations
les externalités etc je pense qu'il faut
sortir toute la trousse à outils
économiques pour voir comment on
derrière la planification par les gens
remarqueront mais les outils pour que
tout le monde tout le monde avance avec
un peu de carotte un peu de bâton et que
tout ça tout ça progresse il faut aussi
croire à la finance ça c'est mon bébé
le sg le sg c'est bien mais là c'est
comme la rse je pense que c'est une
première étape
dire que le psg s'est dit oui ils vont
plutôt dans la bonne direction ils ont
compris que c'était important
on mesure pas grand chose et on vérifie
pas beaucoup en bout de course mais
enfin peut-être qu'il faut en passer par
l'offre peut être accéléré pour la suite
il ya un rôle très important des
différents acteurs haute et économiques
des pouvoirs publics bien sûr la société
civile la question la planification
c'est pas non plus le penseur dans son
bureau qui va dire voilà comment on va
faire c'est ça au delà du tableur excel
faut mobiliser les gens faut qu'ils
acceptent qu'ils comprennent ce qui se
passe est une question centrale je crois
d'accompagnement social j'ai bien aimé
ce que des gens marque sur pas proposer
de désespoir parce que ces cas là c'est
pas possible ça bloque et d'une certaine
manière le coville a été un bon test
on a pu voir enfin vous l'avez rappelé
dans vos différentes entreprises la
capacité d'innovation de mobilisation
des gens on savait pas trop en fait
et puis finalement ça s'est il ya des
gens qui sont allés ça c'est fait et
c'est sylvie la rapée chateaubriand
j'avais utilisé dans mon premier bouquin
comme comme citation du mercure descend
révolution française les moments de
crise propose un redoublement bis les
hommes oui bah là on a une crise qu'est
ce que serait ce qu'on va être capable
de mobiliser ses redoublements de vie
donc on va avoir besoin de tout ça c'est
encourageant marqué dit qu'on soit
réunis ici aujourd'hui
la barre est encore haute alors est-ce
qu'on choisit passer au dessus ou en
dessous
je ne sais pas encore je peux faire et
qu'on passe au dessus et qu'on
s'entraîne un peu un peu plus vite
on a une vraie carte à jouer pour la
france et ça j'y crois beaucoup d'autant
plus vivant aux etats unis je pense que
la france et l'europe ont quelque chose
à dire entre la chine les etats unis sur
ces questions là il faut pas se raconter
d'histoires c'est pas juste parce qu'on
est bien c'est parce qu'on puisse et de
bénéfice pour nous alors je conclurai en
disant un j'ai appris le rôle des
chameaux ce n'était pas qu'une
alternative bas carbone transports en
commun donc ça merci merci de nous avoir
appelé ce point deuxièmement se rappeler
que d'affronter le changement climatique
ça veut dire changer le monde c'est
changer le monde bien sûr et c'est se
changer soi même et tolstoï nous le
rappelle je voulais après châteauroux et
en finir par tout le monde
de changer le monde on a beaucoup plus
de mal à se changer soi même
merci beaucoup merci à tous pour cet
échange a retrouvé donc en replay sur le
site des rencontres
merci à tous très bonne journée
[Musique]